hello we're glad you'd join us for this
live webinar investigating the genetics
of human macrophage response and
resistance to micro bacterium
tuberculosis with Abbas's gene
expression panels
I am Marjorie Torres of laberd's and
I'll be the moderator for this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by libraries the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific Ion Torrent Thermo
Fisher Scientific incorporation is the
world leader in saving science with
revenues of eighteen billion dollars in
more than 55,000 employees globally
their mission is to enable the customers
to make the world healthier cleaner and
safer they help their customers
accelerate life sciences usage solve
complex analytical challenges improve
patient diagnostics and increase
laboratory productivity through their
premier brands thermo scientific applied
Biosystems Invitrogen Fisher Scientific
and Nene D lab services they offer an
unmatched combination of innovative
technologies purchasing convenience and
comprehensive support form
visit www.sap.com/learnbi portray the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind did you so simply type them in the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green Q&A budget at the lower left
with the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slides window click on
the green icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation to click on the
support button found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the green Q&A
button at lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and
the process of obtaining your credit and
that presented a speaker audrie Pott
audience is a research and technical
directors of the pharmacogenomics coral
laboratory at the Ohio State University
College of Medicine Center for
pharmacogenomics as technical director
Audrey played a leading role in
implementation of next-generation
sequencing in the pharmacogenomics Cora
laboratory in her career audrey has been
successful at design and implementation
of new concepts and programs involved
research in clinical areas previously a
supervisor of the clinical molecular
pathology laboratory in the Department
of Pathology at the Ohio State
University Medical Center she played a
key role in developing the tester folio
and establishing the molecular pathology
of laboratory as a CLIA certified lab
author pap will now begin her
presentation hi everyone Thank You
Marjorie and thank you for laboratory
with educational webcast and for thermo
fisher Ion Torrent for inviting me to do
it and i think everybody already got a
lot of information so so I do want to
say that I don't work for thermo Fisher
and neither I nor any of our lab members
receive any compensation for doing this
and also just the legal disclaimer that
Thermo Fisher Scientific is really not
responsible for the work that I'm
presenting this is from our lab so today
I'm going to talk about a project that's
fairly new to our lab or investigating
the genetics of human macrophage
response and resistance to Mycobacterium
tuberculosis and we're using ampliseq
gene expression panels to do that and in
spite of my disclaimer we actually are
an ion torrent certified service
provider or a fairly small Research
Corps lab but we did have to pass fairly
rigorous proficiency testing to be
designated as a certified service
provider so to get to my talk
it's a pretty packed talk I'll be
talking first a little bit about
epidemiology and biology of tuberculosis
and the host response and then I'll look
at our approach to the experiment to
looking at these host responses and I'll
be losing looking at the amplified human
transcriptome analysis and then
different ways that we're analyzing that
and then another thing that I hope to
leave you with is information on how to
use some of the other essentially free
databases that are out there if you're
generating your own data there's just a
wealth of information that you can use
to help form and and test your
hypotheses so to get to the talk here
here in Columbus Ohio when I say I'm
investigating looking at tuberculosis a
lot of people say why are you doing that
you know we thought that that was cured
but the truth is it's really it's a huge
global problem I mean there are 1.3
million deaths per year this was in 2012
it's just up to 30% of the population is
infected with TB so although it might
not be prevalent in the exact location
where you're at it is it's a it's a big
problem it's a big problem so and part
of the problem with tuberculosis is it's
a little bit insidious people are
exposed to TB to the bacteria it's
airborne
some people are exposed and they're not
infected so about 10 to 20 percent of
the people seem to be naturally
resistant and then the people that are
infected who have a latent TB infection
most of them it doesn't progress so you
can't even tell they're infected unless
you do some additional testing and they
met may never have symptoms of
tuberculosis they're just silently
carrying it there is a bag of vaccine
that can be given the BCG vaccine and
this is a really good vaccine for
infants and for children it
protects against extra pulmonary
tuberculosis and it protects against a
lot of other infectious diseases but it
seems to lose its protection in
adulthood so the BCG vaccine is really
good for kids but it doesn't protect
against pulmonary tuberculosis in adults
and maybe a little bit worse than the
most common way for testing for
tuberculosis presence is to test and see
if there's an antibody response and
everybody that's been given this BCG
vaccine has an antibody response so that
they look like they're infected whether
they are or not so it's really hard to
tell the difference between somebody
that is just reacting to the vaccine or
actually has tuberculosis so there's a
real need for better vaccines for
tuberculosis things that will protect
protect against pulmonary TB in
adulthood and even protect against
infection in the first place so that's
kind of where we're approaching it from
a genomic standpoint and part of the
problem is that human variation affects
the susceptibility in response both to
de burgle OSIS into the vaccines so for
our particular project our goal is to
identify common genetic variants in
response gene networks across the
population that contribute to these
variations that impact Burkle osis and
we also want to validate these variants
as functional biomarkers so ideally you
could test for these particular variants
you have a biomarker panel that would
guide in both the development of
vaccines by identifying specific types
of pathways to target in particular
people and also target better treatment
for people that are infected and even to
potentially who to predict who might in
fact progressed from latent TB to
pulmonary TB or not so our project
alveolar macrophages amino Biology and
functional genomics
unlocking human to human variation in
host response to M tuberculosis and this
is funded by the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and this is kind of the
brainchild of both Larry Schlesinger who
was here at Ohio State University until
just recently and also my boss Wolfgang
today
so Larry is the microbiologist and
Wolfgang is the genomics person and what
we're doing is taking human alveolar
macrophages that essentially the first
cell involved in CHEM TB infection we're
taking these from normal donors and
we're looking at both the RNA and the
genomic DNA and we're looking at
responses to infection of these cells
with tuberculosis we're measuring some
of the cellular phenotypes including the
uptake of the bacteria and the survival
of the bacteria and the growth and we're
trying to pull that all together to find
candidate genes that are involved in
these expression pathways and then find
the functional genetic variants in these
exact samples so the nice thing is we
have specific samples and we can look at
the specific genetics and the response
and the bacterial growth in these
samples so the basis for this is MTB
cell association and growth and being
able to relate that so the time course
of MTB infection
initially the bacteria just sit on the
cell on the macrophage and then Baggio
cytosis they're taken up and then in the
next 24 hours the bacteria and the cell
adapt to the MTB infection so different
biochemical and genetic processes and
then after that MTB starts growing and
one of the advantages that our team has
is Larry's group has a lot of work has
done a lot of work with this
chemiluminescence
MTB bacteria so it's been engineered
that it will create chemiluminescence so
you can use that to actually measure the
amount of bacteria there that are in the
cells so for these experiments were
looking at the light units produced by
the bacteria and we're looking at 2
hours to look at the fragile cytosis
we're looking at 24 hours to look at the
adaptation and then we're looking at the
growth at 48 and 72 hours so we can look
at the proliferation of the cells and
see how they're doing again in these
individual donors and just without even
going into the expression analysis of
this data we've done 28 donors so far
and one interesting thing is just
looking at the uptake already there
appear to be two distinct groups of
individuals one high uptake group and
one low uptake group and there's not
much overlap between them so this is one
of the things that we're looking at and
here I want to mention a Bullas ID who
is the PhD that has worked with Louis
Schlesinger and moved with Larry to
Texas biomedical Institute who is doing
all of the MTB cellular infection
experiments so another again just
interesting pattern this is now looking
at the growth in the macrophages and
what you can see from this is if you
look at the stars most of the samples
most of the cell cultures have a pretty
similar pattern but once again there are
a couple of a couple of individuals that
are outliers where there's either
greatly decreased growth in that 24 to
72 hour period or there's increased
growth and once again we think this is
due in part to the genetic background
this is in tissue culture dishes now so
it's most likely to be the genetics that
are influencing this
so a key part of what we're doing is
looking at the gene expression um and a
lot of times people ask me why are we
using ion ampliseq transcriptomes for
this there are lots of transcriptome
methods and one of the bottom lines is
that we honestly we really really like
this assay part of it is it's just it's
a really easy essay to do it's a one
tube assay for the most part so you take
your RNA and you need 10 nanograms or
less of RNA and you put your RNA in a
tube and then you make a master mix and
for all of you samples you add that same
master mix to the tube so everything
gets treated to the same then you do
some incubation you make another master
mix and you add that to the same tubes
these go on they amplify for 12 to 16
cycles so not a lot and then you make
another master mix and add that to all
of the tubes then you put in your
specific adapters and all of this time
this has been in a single tube you're
not taking out you're not putting back
you're not cleaning you're not treating
anything any differently so it's a very
kind of satisfying essay to do in the
lab because you're just not worried
about too much besides getting your you
know your volume into the tube and this
in our lab is done for the most part by
Mandi Williams and she's just she's the
hands in the heart of our layout and you
see her picture down in the corner so
ampliseq what do you would you get with
ampliseq transcriptomes
you get about 21,000 transcripts human
genes assayed it's a gene detection it
uses sequencing so it's a digital
detection it's not analog it's digital
you can count the number of reads that
helps make it quantitative and we see it
easily over five orders of magnitude its
quantitative it's linear
the amplicons are small so that you can
use the
in fairly degraded samples now they
align to a bed file a data file that's
very specific for the amplicons the
amplify amplicons so this is using the
human genome as a reference and then
looking for the specific amplicon
locations in the human genome and this
is also these replicates just correlate
amazingly well both between library
replicates and between sequencing chips
and then one last thing I just had
reason to look at gene clusters it seems
like in these immuno genes and
inflammatory genes there are a lot of
clusters of genes that seem to be
produced by duplications and
replications trying to fine-tune the
expression so this particular cluster is
a triggering receptor expressed in
monocytes the trem gene cluster they're
like eight trem genes that are all very
similar so in looking at our results I
wanted to make sure that these trem
genes were in fact that we were getting
McCrum genes that we thought that we
were so this little picture at the
bottom just shows where the forward and
reverse primers are placed in the
ampliseq panels this is just this is
again this is available from Ion Torrent
on their ampliseq page so this is
available information but what we what I
found out what I can see is that they've
been designed to pick up very
specifically the different genes and
they're also designed very specifically
to pick up the functional isoforms so
this again this is just reassuring in
the context of the biology that we're
looking at that we're in fact looking at
the important gene transcripts with this
empathy panel so this is an example of
some of the first data that we got on
the macrophage RNA and a couple of
things that I wanted to sort of point
out some things that I look at these
read length histograms
here you can see that the the
amplification that the primers the size
is very consistent these look really
nice the distribution of the end-to-end
reads is good but something that I
wanted to share with you that it's
really just based on our experience I
wanted you to see this is just this is a
really good example if you look at this
number of targets detected that's the
number of actual gene transcripts that
are detected just if you look at this
one with the dotted red line here I see
that there are 53% of the targets
detected and this is about four and a
half million reads here you see that
there are 58 percent of the target's
detected so about a five percent
increase and the number of reads is
about doubled so this is a rule of thumb
that actually I find that we can use
pretty broadly is that for these
ampliseq transcriptomes essentially
after about a million reads every time
you double the number of reads you get
about a 5% increase in the number of
targets that you detect so to me this is
a kind of a good rule of thumb if you're
doing these a lot of times the question
is how deep do I need to sequence how
many reads do I need and of course the
answer is always it depends on how you
know how low a transcript level you want
to detect but in general you're only
going to gain about 5% more at that low
end if you double your number of reads
so that's just a secret that I'm
imparting to everybody on this webinar
so another reason that we like ampliseq
this is characterizing it's looking at
the normalization of the transcriptomes
and the top panel this is done by sam
Handelman who's now the analysis is done
by sam Handelman who's now at Wayne
State University but if you normalize
the
you see transcriptome reads they
normalized very very well with a
standard deviation even over 12 fold
from one to twelve million reads with a
standard deviation of about 11 percent
so this is actually this is very tight
very good normalization so that when
you're trying to compare samples with
different number of reads you need about
20 with about 20 to 25 samples you
essentially have the power to detect
your expression changes confidently and
the difference this is their lower panel
is RNA seek this again this is from the
genotype tissue expression database this
is just again available data this is
done by the Broad Institute it's not by
our lab and they are just the gold
standard of sequencing but if you look
at the normalization of whole
transcriptome RNA seek you get almost a
50% of 47.5% standard deviation so it
really means that you need more reads
and you need way more samples in order
to get a very confident measure of
changes in your gene expression so one
of again just to you know kind of
reiterate one of the great benefits of
ampliseq is it's so stable and it's so
consistent and so reproducible that we
can get by with many fewer samples and
feel like we can measure significant
changes in gene expression so if you
can't tell we really like this assay for
gene expression so why is normalization
important why why do we want to look at
normalization and read counts and
differences and the bottom line is in
most experiments you're looking at
changing conditions and you want to see
differentially expressed genes what
changes when you add some sort of what
what
you're looking at a response what
changes so we use differential
expression we calculate the significance
of the difference in the expression
changes and in order to do that we also
need to normalize those read counts so
that like I said we're confident that
we're looking at real changes in gene
expression so another just sort of
setting the stage for why it's important
to have a good normalization of the team
expression and a lot of people ask
what's the best method you want to look
at differentially expressed genes what's
the best way to do that um and
unfortunately here there's no really
best answer this is just this is taking
some of our macrophage data and this is
she leland is a professor of statistics
at Ohio State University and she'll Faye
is one of her students who's been
analyzing our data and what they looked
at is using four different methods of
calculating differential expression
essentially they got four different sets
of results and each each method gave
about 700 or so genes but they weren't
always the same genes so overall this
gave us about 1200 genes that looked
like they were differentially expressed
and the overlap between those was about
300 or about 25% so kind of what I
intend is a take-home message is that if
you're looking at differential
expression if you want to cast a broad
net and not miss too much then you
probably want to look at different ways
of calculating differential expression
and take those into account and if you
want to narrow it to your most relevant
most important candidates you probably
again want to use many methods but then
you can limit it to only the overlaps of
those genes so again another example
these are in our first I think 10 lvl or
Macker
samples and something that struck me
right away with this is that you can see
that when we cluster this and missus
using the torrent suite software no I
mean no additional math when we cluster
this first of all the samples break down
by time point so the cells whether
they're treated or not you can divide
them into the two hour the 72 hour and
the 24 hour time points so most things
are happening to most cells similarly
and then an additional breakdown is that
if you look at pairs of samples so this
is one example and for the most part if
they're sequential they're they're pairs
in this case seven is infected and eight
is uninfected there's also the pair's
cluster together more so than the treat
than with the treatment itself more so
than whether they're infected or
uninfected so might to me the
implication of this is that there's this
overall transcriptomic response and that
that's even more specific the whole
transcriptome response is specific to
individuals and then you get down to the
very specific response in this case to
MTB so it's a much smaller number of
genes that actually differentiate the
response to tuberculosis or probably any
other drug or condition and in a way
this is reassuring if you're trying to
figure out what are the most important
genes that you have to look at so it
looks like it's not this 22,000 it
actually does boil down to a much
smaller number that's relevant
so again going from our specific data or
plugging our differential expression
analysis into integrated pathway
analysis just IPA and one of the things
that came up in just our our first
experiment is one of the pathways
looking excel cell signaling and
interactions there was a difference
between several of the donors this slide
is a little bit fuzzy but I think that
you can see that here il10 this is
interleukin 10 it's kind of a hub gene
that's triggering this in one one set of
donors and here it's interferon gamma
that's triggering a different if it's a
different hub that's triggering a
different set of genes being upregulated
and downregulated and this is this is
interesting in part because interferon
gamma is actually pro-inflammatory and
il-10 is an anti inflammatory molecule
so and both of these have been
implicated in tuberculosis already so
one of the things kind of the next part
of the talk is I want to show you how we
followed up specifically on interleukin
10 to see whether there might be very
specific variants that are important in
this TB response so this it's a lot of
words on this slide the bottom line is
that Isleton influences three important
functions of the monocytes it influences
the release of immune mediators it
influences antigen presentation and also
fragile psychosis the uptake and it acts
to suppress most of these functions so
it's an anti-inflammatory sort of
molecule that we're looking at and I'm
going to walk you through some of the
databases that we used to dig into this
but I want to give you a few just few
definitions just in case you're not used
to the jargon of you know our discipline
so looking at quantitative trait locus
this is really looking at a section of
DNA that correlates with some variation
in phenotype so that's the quantitative
trait is the variation in the phenotype
and then the DNA is the locus and if
we're looking at expression quantitative
trait loci or eqtls we're looking at how
that locus how that section of DNA
affects RNA expression levels so I think
I'll probably throw out eqtl words a lot
so that's what eqtls are um the genotype
tissue expression database it's a
program from the Broad Institute and we
use this database really extensively the
online data resource you can go to to
through the gtex portal and it has just
an abundance of data of you know
aggregated level data and it's got
statistics on the expression
quantitative trait loci analysis another
jargon or G wasps looking at genome-wide
Association studies they are looking at
common genetic variants to see if in
different individuals usually many
different individuals to see if any of
the genetic variants are associated with
a measured trait and then last on this
page DB gap is the database of genotypes
and phenotypes and it's just a
repository for all of these G wasps
results so you whoever is listening can
access these databases and use this
information to look at your gene
expression and to look at your traits
and try and correlate things which is
what we did with aisle 10 and just one
more example and to me this this makes a
really good gives a really good picture
of why gene expression is important if
you look at the great gray dots
is from gtex each dot represents an eqtl
locus so a locus that's linked with
changes in RNA expression and then
underneath if you look at the turquoise
bars
those are trait those are genetic loci
that are linked with phenotypes with
human phenotypes and to me the most
striking part of this you can see all of
the circles is how often the expression
traits the expression levels are linked
to low side that also have phenotypes
that have G loss phenotypes so this
implies very strongly that changes in
RNA expression are actually responsible
for the changes in the phenotypes of the
participants so this is one of the
reasons why we think that expression and
studying expression and genetic changes
for expression is really important so
taking this to aisle 10 again you can do
this for your favorite genes aisle 10 it
looks like it's a pretty simple gene
these red dots are the eqtls and the
higher or lower they are the greater the
p-value for them the probability that
they're significant and these all look
about the same and if you look at the G
waz hits from DB gap there's one in
particular this rs.15 one eight one one
one is the identifier um it has the
strongest expression quantitative trait
locus and it's also linked the most
strongly to Bichette disease which is an
autoimmune disease so this is suggesting
that il-10 function is linked to an
expression is linked to some autoimmune
diseases this also it's involved in
Crohn's disease and other inflammatory
diseases so again it kind of makes sense
aisle 10 interleukin 10 seems to be
important
in immune response so if you dig deeper
though I had thought in looking at this
I was going to be presenting a very easy
resolution of okay this rs.15 one eight
one one one is a causative variant and
all of these other variants just travel
with it on the same chromosome so that
they're linked to it but not important
and the less linked they are maybe the
less important they are but when I broke
this down into different p-values into
different groups it really turned out
that there are at least three groups of
variants and in fact they're grouped
according to different populations
so this rs.15 one eight one one one was
had a very tight group in the African
population but that wasn't as tightly
linked in the CEU and the European
population the linkage seemed to
deteriorate between the green snips and
another one came up in the European
population same thing HCB is the han
chinese population and there's an
entirely different group of variants
that seemed to be linked again to
regulation of Isleton expression so even
if it looks simple it isn't so this
slide this is this is about an hour's
worth talk in itself and I'm trying to
give you a synopsis the punchline is
that there's an Isleton splice variant
that's influenced by this rs.15 one
eight one one one and this is this
actually it's most strongly related to
rs.15 one eight one one one and when
that is present and also this additional
variant is present it makes
a splice form that is a little bit
longer and it's not functional and in
the African époque in the African
population these variants are very very
strongly linked missus this is a
database called snap if you can see in
the bottom left corner and I just drew a
horizontal line showing you that the
variants in this urban population the
African population are tightly tightly
they all occur together whereas you look
at the same variance in the European
population and they don't and just a
plug this database is called snap and
Andrew Johnson was a student of ours
many years ago he's now at NIH and he
developed this database but like I said
what this is telling us is there's this
group of variants in the five prime end
that act best that have their best
function when they're all together and
when they're all together they make this
new splice form that kind of diverts the
interleukin-10 transcript into a
non-productive transcript so what this
does is it potentially increases the
immune response so when you have these
variants together and then it
potentially increases the immune
response so decreases the anti
inflammatory response in people that
possess this group of variants so there
like I said there there were different
variants that were linked in the
European population and different
variants that were linked in different
mechanisms in different populations and
all of these seem to imply that nature
is evolving different mechanisms in
different areas of exposure to regulate
the production of interleukin 10 in
response to the circumstances so just a
little bit of follow up on that
particular variant the one five one
eight one one one we collaborated with
Kathy
deine she has a very wonderful jiwa
study from Ugandan Africans looking at
TB susceptibility in people that reside
in the same household and she shared her
data with us and in fact in this South
African population you can see that
these two variants occur with the same
frequency and they're much more highly
expressed they occur much more
frequently in the cases than in the
controls so that it seems to be a very
direct link to tuberculosis
susceptibility in this population and
these two variants so again it's all
sort of pulling together this hypothesis
that these variants are important in
response to TB and particularly these
variants in this linkage which occurs
most frequency frequently in the African
population okay so that was a lot about
how to use these databases and how to
pull that data together we have one more
topic that I wanted to introduce you to
and this is to look at allelic
expression analysis to very specifically
test for the presence of variants that
change expression and we can do this
we've done this for many years either
using individual assays where we
quantitate snip by snip variant by
variant by measuring at heterozygous
places in the RNA looking at the way the
RNA is expressed more recently we did
that with whole transcriptome sequencing
and the suit the single variant approach
is very precise it's very accurate
the RNA see total RNA seek approach
gives you a ton of information but it
needs a lot more reads and a lot more
depth and it's a lot more confusing so
what we've moved to what we're just
moving to is looking at
with expression so looking at changes in
RNA expression where there's a variant
that we can differentiate the two
alleles one from mom one from dad we're
looking at allylic expression assays and
we've designed - we want to do this on
our specific macrophages on the
macrophage RNA in our specific samples
so we have this RNA we've infected the
cells and we have controls and we have
the time points and we've used their
bioinformatics to take our top 700
candidate genes and Ion Torrent
um in part and payback for me giving
this webinar agreed to do a white glove
amplify assay development in order to
test allylic expression and we just got
the results of the assay we've got about
our seven hundred genes designed for so
we're going to use this amplify to look
at allylic expression and to correlate
it with the donor genotypes that we have
in our specific donors and relate those
to the individual functional variants so
we can trace this back not just
statistically but individually we can
look at the contribution of the
genotypes to the RNA expression so one
last example this is just an example of
what we're looking at with the AM
Placitas
the dark lines represent areas of the
transcript that are expressed in in the
RNA that processed RNA so what we're
looking at our designing amplicons
having them design amplicons that
surround arm variants that surround
common variants so that they would be
heterozygous so that's what our am
place' design was for we had done a
previous design for less for fewer
variants that looked promising so now
we're
at about 700 genes so just to summarize
essentially some of the things that that
I hope I've conveyed in this talk MTB is
honestly a very important worldwide
human pathogen and we need to develop
personalized vaccinations and treatment
for tuberculosis
macrophages are the first responders for
pulmonary TB so that they're an
important component both of the cept
ability and also protection and their
inherent and very measurable differences
in the macrophage responses to MTB even
in these 28 dividuals that we've looked
at so far so overall it looks like
there's a big genetic component that we
can potentially measure in MTB and the
way that we're doing it is using these
empathy transcriptome gene expression
assays because they give us the
sensitivity and reproducibility that we
need without having to do hundreds to
thousands of samples and then based on
the gene expression data and linking
that to the biological data and then
pulling in the information from the
external databases we can hone in pretty
well on individual variants that seem to
be important that seemed to be
functional and then retest that in those
individuals that we have and then apply
that to the broader worldwide population
so again just a summary of our project
in general we're looking at the
associations between RNA expression and
cellular responses to TB and macrophages
then we're modeling our RNA expression
networks to get our key genes then we're
looking to identify genetic variants in
those key genes then we're using allylic
expression and other assays to determine
the effect of those specific variants
and then we're using the information
from these large databases and
associations to make it relevant to a
larger population and hopefully we can
integrate all of this information to
guide both development of vaccines and
also to find an effective personalized
treatment for tuberculosis okay and
these um Larry Schlesinger and Wolfgang
today are the PI's on this project and a
lot of help a lot of informatics help
especially from XI Leland and Gregor and
Paulo who are professors at Ohio State
University
but the hands-on stuff everything that
I've presented has been by these people
by Ebola side and Mindy Williams
shellfish au min Wong my GP Pietro
Jaclyn long is also a professor and Sam
Handelman and this project was funded by
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation it
is a pilot project and we're hoping for
more funding so that's my talk thank you
now we can open up for questions if you
wish thank you odd and Pat for your
presentation a quick reminder for
audience and how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box then by
clicking on the green Q&A button as a
little left of the presentation window
audio pop will answer as many questions
as time for miss the first question is
can this approach of combining genotype
cellular phenotype and expression be
applied to other diseases oh I think
this would honestly in my opinion be
kind of an obvious approach to other
diseases cancer is is one of them where
you can look at a tumor versus a normal
tissue and you look and look in that
individual but you could also look at
drug treatments I mean anything where
there's essentially a specific phenotype
that you could test I think this would
be a good approach for thank you the
next question is as a core lab what
projects have you seen we're using a
single and now
suppose say I on am beside transcriptome
has been sufficient um it's more the
single question where amplify gives a
single answer so again I think one of
the better examples is if you're looking
to see how a drug affects the the growth
of a cell you can add the drug use the
amplify transcriptomes to look at gene
expression and get a very clear-cut
answer very clear-cut effect measurement
of how the gene expression has changed
what that drug has done the next
question is how do you use other sources
of RNA outside of ham yeah that's a good
question it's one of the things that we
like ampliseq for a lot we've we've used
it with FFPE formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded RNA so this is usually
a nightmare to look at with sequencing
with transcriptome expression because
it's so degraded but with ampliseq we've
done studies with quite a few
investigators now looking at RNA
prepared from the FFPE and it really
works remarkably well you do need
roughly hundred base pair fragments in
order for ampliseq to work and the other
thing is it appears and I'm not sure why
but it seems to me that ampliseq with
FFPE works best on newer samples and I
don't know if it's the fixation methods
or oxidation or something else but over
about five to ten years after about five
years the number of targets that we
detect goes down but the other the other
use that I'm kind of excited about that
is just a very recent project is we're
looking at some laser capture samples
and in these laser capture samples we
don't even have a measurable amount
RNA in the samples but we are putting we
are performing the amplified
transcriptome essay and honestly we're
getting beautiful expression results you
know full number of valid targets that
we would expect from these unmeasurable
amounts of RNA from the laser capture
samples so it's not quite single cell I
haven't we haven't really applied it to
single cell but with laser capture in a
very small number of cells and targeted
cells it seems to work really well it
looks like we have time for one more
question this is an interesting study
what is happening next in the project um
so we have the biological responses and
I just showed you those brief slides
where with veggie psychosis an uptake
and with growth curves there seem to be
differences in different individuals so
one of the first things that we're doing
for this study is following up with the
expression studies and the network
studies and trying to figure out which
genes are important for those phenotypes
for those biological phenotypes for the
uptake of the bacteria and for the
growth of the bacteria and the
macrophages so those expression profiles
and those expression analysis and
combining it with the biological is
really the the next step for us and
trying to look at what genes are
important and what variants then might
influence that plus the allylic
expression assays I'm excited to see the
results of those
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions I would also like
to thank audrie Pott for her
presentation we would like to we would
also like to thank our sponsors Thermo
Fisher Scientific
Ion Torrent for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through December 2017
labret will let you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye bye everyone